hi there Steve Kaufman here um I'm
leaving tomorrow for China today I had a
easy day here in Vancouver the weather
was it did rain but it was overcast
while I prepared myself and and you know
I was thinking about something that has
come up partly as a result of what we're
doing at link and that is the degree to
which language learning needs to be an
interactive learning process and as many
of you know I stayed here what I like to
do and number of people disagree some
come on and comment and disagree some
people just give me the thumbs down
that's fine but I still like to stay you
know what what I believe in so far as
language learning is concerned and I one
of the areas where I think I disagree
the most with even the more progressive
parts of mainstream language teaching is
in this need for sort of interactivity
in the early stages of learning an
example what we do at link is is very
close to the theories of TP rx which is
teaching proficiency through reading and
storytelling very much input based I
agree with it I think it's great and I
don't know much beyond what i have read
on the internet about it but it seems to
you know except the fact that people
will learn from stories from listening
from lots of reading but the
practitioners of tprs like to prepare
stories where a very limited number of
words and phrases are repeated maybe 50
times in the story in the hope that then
those words and phrases will really be
absorbed by the learner personally I
find myself resisting that I think a
story that is construed to have that
same or this limited number of words and
phrases appear so often will be
uninteresting
I don't think that however often I hear
certain words and phrases that I will
necessarily nail them down I know that
in my check learning certain words you
know not necessarily obscure but words
that mean you know like I think of pune
budge or protege which means because but
other words like Kanye coud comes up all
the time I look it up I still don't know
what it means I must have looked it up
10 times it's come up all the time I
looked it up i forget it so you know
repetition is not going to ensure it's
like I always say you can't nail things
down one day for whatever reason that
word will fall into place and i'll be
able to use it in the meantime every
time i come across it i have to look it
up even though i've come across at many
many times other words i see them once i
remember so you know this also came up
we have started at link offering some
lessons from lingua phone integrated
with the link system that caused a
little bit of a controversy at link
because the lingua phone style is very
different from our more passive input
based learning style at link but you
know there are different kinds of
learners but one of the things that they
like to do is have the learner even in
the beginning lessons sort of listen and
repeat and much more sort of complete a
word so if the word is señorita they
will say send yo D and you have to go
senorita so again it's an effort to
engage the learner in doing something
pimpster does this as well Tim star asks
you questions prompts you to answer
questions most language learning systems
seem to do this they ask you to you no
answer your question about the text that
you have heard or change the tents of
something constantly asking you to do
something I don't like doing those
things I think they slow you down and
that's perhaps where
I'm interested in feedback I mean to me
the task is to acquire words and and and
to immerse yourself in the language and
the minute I'm asked to change the tents
of something in a sentence or two you
know remember whether the lady you know
what she bought at the store or any such
comprehension questions that just throws
me off my track if I take my own example
now with check which which I started
from scratch at link here i am with less
than three months under my belt and I'm
picking my way through a book that was
written you know in the 1920s or
whenever it was written the good soldier
schwake and I'm loving it because it
brings me back into that period of the
austro-hungarian empire on the evolving
during the First World War and I
occasionally go to to look up certain
things relating to that period in
history I'm not at the point where i
have another book are unchecked history
which i'm reading away from the computer
so i can't import it into link
unfortunately there's lots of words i
don't know but i can still follow it so
I'm just passively ingesting the
language and tremendously enjoyable when
I go to speak let's say in three or four
months from now I will have a tremendous
vocabulary at my disposal I don't need
seems to me in Lesson one to repeat you
know proto j.j protégé or any such you
know word I don't need to be prompted to
start using the language in an
artificial way when I go to use it in a
natural and meaningful way I will
struggle and and so the same also
applies to you know this shadowing which
is and you know there are people who
swear by this and say it's very
effective so I'm not saying that it
isn't I'm just saying that I don't find
it to be the case I have tried repeating
after or even some people like to read
out loud memorize and these are all
things that I I just can't continue
doing I do a little
of them just to try them out doesn't
seem to have much effect and I just
revert back to my passive call it
passive learning but when we are
learning passively through listening and
reading and reviewing words and phrases
this passive learning is a form of
interaction we are interacting with the
language we're interacting with words or
interacting with meaning we're entering
this other language world creating
associations surely that's interactive
I'm not sure it's less meaningful
interaction than being forced to you no
answer something on cue or finish a word
or any of those other things that are
you know an attempt to engage us before
we're ready to be engaged and I also as
I said earlier I don't think that all of
that activity is going to enable you to
nail down any vocabulary because if if
you are doing a story and it has three
words and three phrases repeated 50
times and at the end of a week even if
you could match to those three words in
three phases it's only three words and
three phrases besides I said all that
you can match them if I look at at my
own results in check with less than
three months under my belt I have many
many thousands of words now in my
vocabulary if I have tried to nail every
one of those down at an earlier stage I
think the number of words in my
vocabulary today would number in the
hundreds so there you have it to one
extent and how useful is it to try to
create this interactivity to engage the
learner to force the learner to produce
something to say something to repeat
something is it necessary what are the
pedagogical reasons for it am I
completely wrong and suggesting that
there is another approach which is
easier less stressful and at least in my
case I think leads to better results so
look forward to hearing your comments
bye for now now I my most I can't seem
to
try not to swear why this is going on
here because my mouse wanders into two
screens and I had it not lined up and
here we go so yeah thanks for listening
and for computers